on tourne un reportage parce que je vais
retrouver le plus proche de mes parents
biologiques que j'ai pu retrouver samuel
les amish non pas du tout
some ému et reconnaissant devoir notre
soeur margot de revenir
j'ai toujours respirez vous rencontrez
vous tous c'est un grand moment pour moi
vraiment
pardon je peux vous filmer une minute
[Musique]
j'aime bien ta poupée c'est quoi son nom
sa
maintenance appelé comme ça cela vécu
ici il ya très longtemps elle est
toujours ici
qu'est ce que tu dis
[Musique]
pourquoi construire une église aussi
isolé
c'est quoi ça à ce mode est le démon fut
enfermé dans le corps d'une femme et
c'est déjà arrivé avant
[Musique]
c'est ma mère vous nous aurez pas mon
bébé moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je connais toutes les familles à mischa
plus de 80 bornes à la ronde
la compagnie
ja je suis à kormann ja je suis à koeman
cristaux chanter quand ce
[Musique]
haut
oh mon dieu tu es sûr de ton cou il faut
que je sache
[Musique]